привіт, мене звати Olivia Lan, я дослідниця та викладачка в IBM Quantum. це відео відзначає запуск
абсолютно нової серії на YouTube-каналі Qiskit та на нашій навчальній платформі під назвою Quantum Computing in
practice. коротко кажучи, в цій серії я покажу тобі, як використовувати квантовий комп'ютер, що існує вже зараз, на повну
потужність. в інтернеті вже є мільярди відео про квантові комп'ютери та їхній майбутній потенціал або про теоретичні концепції
квантових обчислень, які теж важливі — наприклад, дивись «Understanding Quantum Information and Computation»
за авторством John Watrous. але в цьому курсі ми припускаємо, що той, хто навчається, вже знає трохи більше,
ніж раніше, і ми підемо дуже далеко з технічної точки зору. а це тому, що за минулий рік — і на момент
цього запису зараз 2024 рік — ми спостерігали зрушення, фазовий перехід, якщо хочеш, в нову еру
обчислень. квантові комп'ютери нарешті наближаються до тієї точки, де вони можуть бути корисними. хоча експерименти з
малими circuit та квантовими комп'ютерами були потрібні, щоб навчити нашу спільноту користуватися цими машинами, ніхто не запускав експерименти,
які не можна було б виконати на звичайних класичних комп'ютерах. але сьогодні ми вступили в еру
квантової корисності. і що таке корисність, спитаєш ти? це відрізняється від Quantum Advantage, яку можна зрозуміти як
точку, в якій квантові комп'ютери перевершують класичні у значущих завданнях. натомість корисність означає,
що вони вже можуть конкурувати між собою — і це природний наступний крок у технологічній
еволюції. IBM опублікувала статтю, яка вперше показала: минулого року квантовий комп'ютер можна використати для
симуляції фізичної моделі і конкурувати з найсучаснішими методами класичної симуляції. він навіть перевершив
методи грубої сили і відкрив дослідникам новий шлях для наукової роботи. то чому ж усе це відбувається
саме зараз? ну, за останні кілька місяців IBM зробила квантові процесори понад 100 qubit широко доступними. якщо ти
вже є користувачем, то, мабуть, помітив, що ми прибрали багато наших менших процесорів, щоб звільнити місце для більших чипів, і ми вважали, що це справді
важливо зробити, адже деяку кількість qubit ще можна симулювати класично без проблем. тому немає
реальної переваги від використання цих чипів. однак при 100 qubit ситуація вже інша — їх не можна
симулювати класично. також важливо зазначити, що існують так звані симулятори —
по суті комп'ютерні програми, які можуть імітувати деяку поведінку квантових систем, включно з шумом. але, будь ласка,
не пропусти слово «імітувати». симулятори — це не квантові комп'ютери, вони не можуть давати результати, які дають
квантові комп'ютери на такому масштабі. але вони все одно є важливою частиною нашого робочого процесу тестування. отже, це була досить
розлога відповідь на питання з початку слайда: що таке практичні квантові обчислення? у цьому курсі я навчу тебе реалістичним
потенційним сценаріям застосування квантових технологій та найкращим практикам запуску й експериментів на цих більших
процесорах сьогодні. то для кого ж цей курс? давай почнемо з базового налаштування.
з самого початку: цей курс для всіх, хто прагне розробляти нові застосунки для квантових комп'ютерів,
хоче знати, як масштабувати свою роботу, або навчитися використовувати квантові технології у своїх поточних процесах. я вже
згадувала, що курс буде дуже практичним і ми не будемо так багато говорити про теоретичні аспекти. ми
очікуємо, що ти прийдеш із базовим розумінням того, що таке квантові обчислення. але якщо ти ще не там — не хвилюйся, просто подивись
перші кілька епізодів курсу John Watrous і ти будеш готовий. ми також хочемо переконатися, що ті, хто дивиться, знають:
це не просто курс для фізиків чи навіть для інформатиків — ці дві дисципліни справді
монополізували квантові обчислення протягом останнього десятиліття або близько того. ми хочемо, щоб інші, хто працює з великими даними або
симуляціями, — наприклад, інженери, хіміки та матеріалознавці — знали, що цей курс також для них. підсумовуючи:
курс орієнтований на широку аудиторію, і ми сподіваємося, що ти пройдеш його повністю. після завершення курсу ти
зможеш зрозуміти, як створювати та запускати завдання масштабу корисності через Qiskit Runtime, включно з повним робочим процесом.
ти зможеш зрозуміти основні типи пом'якшення помилок, а також зрозумієш імовірні сфери застосування в короткостроковій перспективі. ти також зможеш
виконувати всі ці алгоритми в Qiskit, і насамкінець ми очікуємо, що ти зможеш розуміти шум і справлятися з ним.
отже, почнімо! квантові обчислення — це захоплива нова технологія на ранньому етапі розвитку, але це лише
одна глава в історії обчислень, яка налічує тисячі років. я вважаю важливим розуміти цей
контекст, адже він робить те, що ми тут намагаємося зробити, трохи більш інтуїтивним, передбачуваним і менш
схожим на наукову фантастику. з давніх часів ми, люди, потребували виконання обчислень —
іншими словами, обробки інформації відповідно до певних правил і обмежень — щоб забезпечити
комунікацію, будівництво, торгівлю, науку та всі інші аспекти нашого життя. ми зверталися до фізичного світу
по допомогу, і завдяки геніальним відкриттям ми створили пристрої, що допомагають нам обчислювати. колись давно пристрої
виготовлялися з дерева, кісток, мотузок з вузлами — вони зберігали інформацію та полегшували обчислення зовсім інакше, ніж
сьогодні. механічні пристрої з важелями, шестернями та іншими механізмами еволюціонували від ранніх астрономічних годинників до
калькуляторів і складних обчислювальних пристроїв, таких як диференційні аналізатори, що розв'язували рівняння за допомогою коліс і
обертових дисків. навіть технологія письма відіграла важливу роль у цій історії, дозволяючи людям виконувати
обчислення, які інакше були б неможливими. коли ми думаємо про комп'ютери сьогодні, то зазвичай маємо на увазі
електронні цифрові комп'ютери. але це насправді досить нещодавня технологія. перші електронні цифрові комп'ютери
були побудовані в 1940-х роках. найдавніший відомий інструмент для обчислень — це шумерські рахівниці,
які, на думку дослідників, були винайдені у Вавилоні приблизно в 2700–2300 роках до н.е. це справді
дуже давно! але ми дедалі більше пізнаємо природний світ — від Archimedes до Euclid до
Einstein — і наша потреба в обчислювальних ресурсах стрімко зросла. сьогодні у нас є суперкомп'ютери —
по суті, безліч дуже потужних комп'ютерів, з'єднаних паралельно. вони є одним із найкращих інструментів людства для
розв'язання складних задач. але є чимало задач, з якими навіть ці комп'ютери-велетні ніколи не зможуть
впоратися. про це пізніше. отже, ми з'ясували, що люди використовують фізику та природу для своїх обчислень
вже тисячі років. і щоб допомогти нам у нашому нескінченному прагненні обчислювати більше й масштабніше, ти, мабуть, вже
WEBVTT
знайомий із законом Мура. насправді це не зовсім закон — це спостереження. «закон» тут — це трохи
іронія, на мою думку. максимальна кількість транзисторів в інтегральній схемі, тобто по суті в комп'ютерному чипі,
подвоюється приблизно кожні 2 роки. протягом останніх п'яти десятиліть або близько того ми не лише спостерігали це, але й
активно використовували. більше транзисторів дозволяє виконувати більше обчислень і швидше — власне, саме це й відповідає за те,
що комп'ютери стають дедалі потужнішими і меншими з часом. однак є погана новина: закон Мура вмирає.
експерти сперечаються про те, коли саме він прийде до свого неминучого кінця, але дехто каже, що це вже сталося. хоча ми й не знаємо
точно, коли досягнемо межі, ми знаємо, що це врешті-решт неминуче, адже деякі частини транзисторів
фізично неможливо зробити ще меншими. ти ж не зробиш транзистор, менший за атом, — наприклад, це
просто суперечить фізиці. звучить безглуздо, але саме з такими обмеженнями ми й працюємо. то що ж
нам робити — просто здатися і сказати: «ну і ладно, це найкраще, що є»? ні, люди так ніколи не робили. на щастя, квантова
механіка вступила в гру. квантову механіку відкрили в 1920-х роках, і з тих пір світ буквально
ніколи не був таким самим. ми могли б годинами говорити про революційні відкриття, які були
зроблені, але це не є основним фокусом цього курсу. натомість я хочу чітко сказати: ми знаємо, що квантова
механіка та обчислення вже сумісні між собою. знання та розуміння природи,
які ми отримали завдяки квантовій механіці, частково й зробили можливими наші сучасні комп'ютери. без квантової
механіки ми б, напевно, навіть не змогли б зрозуміти або винайти твердотільний жорсткий диск,
наприклад. квантові обчислення — це просто наступний природний крок у цій еволюції.
але обчислення існують не у вакуумі — інформація потребує носія.
обчислення інформації задіюють фізичний світ і впливають на нього. це накладає обмеження на те, що взагалі є
фізично можливим. але розуміння природи та фізичних обмежень — це і є мета фізики як
дисципліни. тож у певному сенсі фізика та обчислення завжди були переплетені. Ralph Landauer — вчений-комп'ютерник та
дослідник IBM — ще десятиліття тому усвідомив, що інформація є фізичною. інакше кажучи, інформація — це не
абстрактна сутність, вона існує лише через фізичне представлення. принцип Landauer встановлює зв'язок
між інформацією та законами термодинаміки. але насправді між фізикою та обчисленнями існує багато зв'язків.
класична фізика була все, що ми могли досліджувати аж до недавнього часу, але з відкриттям квантової
механіки ми опинилися на порозі створення принципово нового способу обчислення. і це чудово, тому що
класичні комп'ютери можуть лише наближено відтворювати те, що насправді відбувається в природі, і в деяких випадках це наближення дуже
обмежене. це тому, що дуже, дуже важко змусити машини, які підкоряються законам класичної фізики,
наближено відтворювати закони квантової фізики. а природа не класична — вона квантова. одна аналогія, яка може допомогти тобі
зрозуміти, — це аеродинамічна труба. аеродинаміка відома тим, що її надзвичайно важко симулювати та передбачати математично.
навіть щось таке буденне, як автомобіль, що рухається крізь вітер. виробники автомобілів з'ясували, що
симулювати цю фізичну взаємодію при проектуванні машин було надто дорого й непрактично. натомість
вони просто побудували справжній тунель, який продуває вітер, і просто заганяють туди автомобіль,
щоб подивитися, як він поводиться. це аналогія до того, що я маю на увазі, коли кажу, що класичні комп'ютери лише погано
наближають природу, і інколи намагатися змусити їх це робити надто дорого. замість симуляції вітру
дослідники просто відтворюють його. аналогічно, квантові комп'ютери не мусять наближати закони природи на
молекулярному рівні, бо вони самі підкоряються цим законам. їм не треба нічого симулювати — вони його емулюють. і
ті самі труднощі виникають, коли ми симулюємо батареї або хімічні реакції, що й підводить нас до наступного
розділу: квантові обчислення — що з них користі?
то навіщо взагалі думати про поєднання квантової механіки та обчислень? ну, вже зараз є чимало
задач, що є надто складними, надто обчислювально затратними навіть для наших найсучасніших суперкомп'ютерів.
можливо, це задачі, на яких зосереджені лише дослідники, але їхній вплив може торкнутися всіх куточків
планети. ці задачі, з якими класичні комп'ютери застрягають, — це те, від чого ми як суспільство стаємо дедалі більше
залежними від технологій, і це справді важливо: ефективність батарей, фінансове моделювання,
оптимізація і навіть проектування кращих літаків. то навіщо звертатися до квантових комп'ютерів? ну, у нас є дуже вагомі підстави
вважати, що тут є великий потенціал, і ми можемо відкрити двері до нових обчислень, недосяжних навіть для
найпотужніших суперкомп'ютерів. теоретично деякі квантові алгоритми дають переваги перед
найкращими класичними алгоритмами для певних застосувань. для інших застосувань є дедалі більше доказів того, що навіть
з деяким шумом і недосконалостями квантові комп'ютери можуть слугувати інструментом для конкуренції з класичними методами грубої
сили. по суті, це абсолютно новий інструмент, і ми хочемо відкрити ще більше цікавих речей, які можна з ним зробити. але ми можемо
також звернутися до оригінальної ідеї Feynman щодо них — використовувати їх для розуміння фізики та природи самих по собі.
зрештою, я вже казала тобі, що природа є квантовою, а не класичною, і ця галузь є неймовірно багатою, захоплюючою і
міждисциплінарною. вона об'єднує фізику, інформатику, обробку інформації і, звісно, конкретні предметні сфери застосування, які
нас можуть цікавити. однак, на відміну від класичних комп'ютерів, не кожен має квантовий комп'ютер у кишені. ще до дуже недавнього часу, якщо ти хотів
поекспериментувати з квантовим комп'ютером, тобі доводилося будувати й обслуговувати
його самостійно — зазвичай у похмурій підвальній лабораторії університету чи дослідницького центру. і повір мені, я це знаю. але більше
це не так. у 2016 році IBM розмістила перший квантовий процесор у хмарі. на той час він мав лише п'ять qubit
і досить високий рівень помилок, але це було лише 8 років тому — і подивись, як далеко ми просунулися. то де ж ми стоїмо сьогодні?
є багато паралелей із самими ранніми днями сучасних комп'ютерів. як я вже згадувала, це дуже
складна задача, і лише за останні 8 років квантові комп'ютери стали широко доступними — крім
тих, хто працював у передових лабораторіях. але за ці вісім років ми зробили прогрес на кожному
WEBVTT
напрямку: процесори стали на порядки більшими за кількістю qubit, gate значно покращилися, і ми запровадили методи
зменшення або пом'якшення помилок, властивих квантовим системам, навіть коли ми рухаємося вперед до створення відмовостійких
квантових комп'ютерів. тепер ти й будь-хто інший може використовувати один із цих численних IBM Quantum процесорів,
розміщених у хмарі, майже всі з яких є найновішими, найсучаснішими системами з понад 100
qubit. але важливий не лише розмір процесорів — це лише одна метрика, яка нас цікавить. і
це логічно, правда? якщо у нас більше qubit, це, очевидно, краще, за умови, що збільшення кількості qubit
не погіршує продуктивність. однак це не завжди так. нам потрібно більше qubit хорошої якості, які не заважають
одне одному через перехресні завади, коли ми цього не хочемо. те, як qubit з'єднані між собою, також важливо пам'ятати: у
надпровідних circuit — це виклик: як найкраще фізично з'єднати qubit. ще одна надзвичайно важлива метрика —
це точність двокубітного gate. gate на одному qubit не так схильні до помилок; двокубітні gate — це набагато
більша зона занепокоєння і зазвичай одна з тих метрик, на які ми орієнтуємося, щоб побачити, як продуктивність покращується з
часом. двокубітні gate вкрай важливо налагодити правильно, адже вони відповідають за створення заплутаності між qubit,
що є одним із фізичних явищ, які дають квантовим комп'ютерам їхню потужність. і нарешті, ми орієнтуємося на швидкість і ефективність:
нам потрібно переконатися, що час виконання програми на квантовому чипі є максимально швидким і ефективним.
разом ці три метрики ми називаємо масштабом, якістю та
швидкістю. всі вони є ключовими для підвищення продуктивності. тепер хочу показати тобі кілька швидких графіків, щоб підтвердити те, що я
кажу про те, як технологія справді дуже швидко розвивається. кількість qubit — найпростіший для розуміння показник,
я вважаю. IBM опублікувала дорожню карту щодо того, де ми сподіваємося бути в найближчі роки з точки зору кількості qubit
та розміру процесора. на 2024 рік, коли ми знімаємо це відео, ми чітко дотримуємося плану з нашими процесорами Heron і Condor. далі —
якість: цей графік показує медіанний рівень помилок заплутувального gate для IBM Quantum процесорів з часом. зверни увагу:
це логарифмічна шкала, тому, хоча прогрес виглядає приблизно лінійним, насправді він набагато швидший.
і нарешті, швидкість: цей графік показує прогрес метрики, яку ми називаємо CLOPS — circuit layer
operations per second. ключово те, що CLOPS охоплює як час виконання circuit, так і необхідні реальні та
майже реального часу класичні обчислення. по суті, CLOPS — це міра того, наскільки швидко наші процесори можуть виконувати певні circuit
послідовно, слугуючи мірою цілісної швидкості системи та поєднуючи квантові і класичні
обчислення. наразі, на момент запису, IBM є єдиним квантовим хмарним провайдером, що надає доступ до машин із 100
і більше qubit. як я вже згадувала кілька слайдів тому, 100 qubit або близько того — це та межа, де класична симуляція
починає повністю провалюватися. тому великомасштабні завдання на цих машинах часто не мають класичного еквівалента — це просто
неможливо. є певні нюанси й хитрощі: можна симулювати одні частини circuit, а інші —
окремо. але загалом ми знаємо, що десь близько цього числа квантові комп'ютери починають робити те, чого класичні просто не можуть. тому
IBM вирішила, що надання доступу до цих більших пристроїв надзвичайно важливо для широкої спільноти, адже все,
що робиться на менших пристроях, можна симулювати класично і, отже, це не може привести до Quantum Advantage. 100-qubit
пристрої, які ми маємо зараз, ще недосконалі й шумні, тому нам треба бути розумними щодо того, як ми запускаємо завдання і
circuit на них. якщо просто написати свій circuit і натиснути Shift+Enter — це, мабуть, не
призведе ні до чого вражаючого. але, знову ж таки, є хитрощі та найкращі практики, які ми можемо застосувати, щоб вичавити ще
більше продуктивності з цих пристроїв — що, сподіваємося, наближатиме нас до Quantum Advantage, поки ми продовжуємо
працювати над нашими відмовостійкими машинами. цей графік показує вартість симуляції —
тобто час, необхідний для розв'язання задачі на класичних комп'ютерах і на квантових комп'ютерах із пом'якшенням і корекцією помилок.
так, лінія класичних обчислень зростає експоненціально із зростанням складності circuit.
для простих circuit тут це не має значення, але воно, очевидно, погане зі зростанням складності, адже це
робить вартість симуляції дуже дорогою дуже швидко. пом'якшення помилок масштабується краще, тому зі зростанням складності
circuit саме тут ми й хочемо бути. зараз ми перебуваємо тут: класичні методи та квантові методи приблизно
на рівних для деяких застосувань. а корекція помилок може бути найкращим варіантом і масштабується дуже
добре — ми просто ще не там. тим часом ми продовжимо зосереджуватися на пом'якшенні помилок і на досягненні
зони квантової корисності якомога швидше. застосовуючи кілька схем пом'якшення помилок, про які ми
дізнаємося в цій серії, ми прагнемо знайти сфери застосування, де можна використовувати квантову корисність дуже скоро. і це є
справжньою суттю цього курсу. у нас є ці машини, і ми вважаємо, що вони здатні робити справді цікаві
дослідження. то як нам їх використовувати? в цьому останньому розділі епізоду давай коротко обговоримо сфери застосування
практичних квантових обчислень. є три основні напрями, які ми найбільше хочемо дослідити й знайти шляхи для квантової
корисності. перший — симуляція природи: це стосується симуляції молекулярних або атомних взаємодій і є
дуже важливим для матеріалознавства і хімії. з причин, які ми вже обговорювали, ми вважаємо, що квантові
комп'ютери впораються з цим набагато краще, ніж їхні класичні колеги. далі — пошук і
оптимізація: основний алгоритм тут — QAOA, гібридний класично-квантовий алгоритм. QAOA використовує
класичний комп'ютер для навчання та знаходження оптимальних параметрів для квантового circuit і, сподіваємося, зможе зробити це
набагато ефективніше, ніж будь-який комп'ютер поодинці. і нарешті, у нас є математика та обробка структурованих даних. квантові
комп'ютери дуже добре знаходять структуру в хаотичних даних там, де ти, я або звичайний комп'ютер можемо
нічого не побачити. квантове машинне навчання є перспективним у цій сфері, і ми прагнемо використовувати це для таких завдань, як витяг
ознак і розпізнавання образів. це справді дуже захоплюючий час для тих із нас, хто працює в
галузі квантових обчислень. вперше в історії ми можемо починати досліджувати область обчислень, що виходить за рамки
класичних обчислень. ті з вас, хто дивиться це, можливо, відіграватимуть роль, подібну до ролі піонерів раннього
комп'ютерного часу. і вони не мали жодного уявлення про те, що буде далі. T. J. Watson з IBM навіть відомо сказав, що, на його думку,
WEBVTT
ринок може бути лише для двох-трьох комп'ютерів будь-коли — і наскільки ж він помилявся!
ми всі є тими ранніми піонерами обчислень, але в цій новій галузі квантових обчислень. і Quantum часто
протиставляється класичним обчисленням як щось принципово відмінне від них і нерідко в конкуренції з ними. але моя
мета в цій вступній лекції — сподіваюся, переконати тебе, що з висоти пташиного польоту ми можемо побачити квантові
обчислення просто як наступний розділ у довгій історії обчислень. це наша природа — як людей — шукати нові способи
обчислювати, використовувати силу природного світу й розбиратися, що з цим робити. і ми робимо це вже
протягом сторіч. квантові обчислення пропонують нам новий інструмент у цьому прагненні, і від нас залежить, як ми зможемо
використати потужність, яку вони нам дають. на наступному уроці серії ми поговоримо трохи більше про 100-qubit системи
та надамо огляд Qiskit — нашого SDK програмного забезпечення для квантових обчислень — і того, як найкраще взаємодіяти з цими машинами прямо зараз. дякую за
перегляд, і побачимося наступного разу!